This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you're listening to this show right now, you certainly understand the influence new products have on the ways we live. But the interesting thing is, that over the course of history, so many products don't so much get newly designed, but get resold to us over and over again, with different packaging. Versions of the same technologies to help us clean, cook, exercise, and sleep. All promising more efficiency and more convenience, attempting to turn our homes,
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你现在正在收听这个节目，你肯定明白新产品对我们生活方式的影响。但有趣的是，纵观历史，许多产品与其说是被重新设计，不如说是换了包装被反复卖给我们。这些技术版本旨在帮助我们清洁、烹饪、锻炼和睡眠。它们都承诺提供更高的效率和便利，试图将我们的家，
to do private little utopias. Or at least, that's the thesis of the podcast Nice Try from New York magazine's Curved. Their first season was all about filled utopian experiments, but their second season makes a turn inward into the private haven of the American dream by looking at all the appliances in it. Nice try also just happens to be hosted by 99PI superstar alumna Avery Trufflement.
变成私人的小乌托邦。或者至少，这是《纽约》杂志旗下Curved播客《Nice Try》的论点。他们的第一季全是关于失败的乌托邦实验，但第二季通过审视美国梦私人避难所里的所有电器，将视角转向了内部。《Nice Try》恰好也由《99PI》的超级校友艾弗里·特鲁夫曼主持。
It's nice to say her name again. Avery Trufflement. So far she's covered how the doorbell turned into the home security system, how the vacuum cleaner went from a public utility to the first widely accepted household robot, and how the crockpot and instant pot cleverly repackaged some of the oldest cooking technologies known to humanity. But the episode we're sharing today is about a self-improvement device that was not intended to make life easier. It was designed specifically to make life just a little bit harder.
很高兴能再次念出她的名字。艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。到目前为止，她已经介绍了门铃是如何演变成家庭安防系统的，吸尘器是如何从公共设施变成首个被广泛接受的家用机器人的，以及慢炖锅和电压力锅是如何巧妙地重新包装了人类已知最古老的烹饪技术的。但我们今天分享的这一集是关于一种并非旨在让生活变得更轻松的自我提升设备。它的设计初衷恰恰是让生活变得稍微困难一点。
And it hasn't changed very much since its invention. This is a story about lifting weights and how it became a central component to home fitness. So this is a full body exercise. Oh, there we go. Yeah, that works. That's what we make. I know where we are. Three more.
而且自发明以来，它并没有发生太大变化。这是一个关于举重以及它如何成为家庭健身核心组成部分的故事。所以这是一个全身运动。哦，开始了。是的，这很有效。这就是我们制造的东西。我知道我们在哪。再做三个。
Alright. Two. One. Can I just introduce the show quickly? This would be a great place to introduce the show. Totally. From New York magazine's curved in the Vox Media Podcast Network. This is nice try. A Mayberry Truffleman.
好的。两个。一个。我能快速介绍一下这个节目吗？这会是一个介绍节目的好地方。当然。来自《纽约》杂志旗下Curved和Vox媒体播客网络。这是《Nice Try》。我是艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。
Alright, should we do some goblet spots? in the Vox Media Podcast Network. This is nice try. I may be trouble, man. I'm worried. All right, should we do some goblet spots? I don't know. I don't know. Let's do that. Let the record show, I totally work out. I'm just usually on team cardio. So I had never swung a kettlebell before.
好了，我们要不要做些高脚杯深蹲？在Vox媒体播客网络。这是《Nice Try》。我是艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。我很担心。好吧，我们要不要做些高脚杯深蹲？我不知道。我不知道。我们做吧。请记录在案，我确实锻炼。我通常是心肺训练派的。所以我以前从没挥动过壶铃。
And when I went to the house of Natalia Melman Petrazella, a historian of physical fitness and a professor at the new school, she had more than enough weights for both of us to work out together. This one is 20 pounds. This one is 35 pounds. That one is 15 pounds, okay? Professor Petrazella roundly kicked my ass at lifting because this is just part of her home and her life. She has these weights and lifts them regularly. Work at equipment and accessories have become canonized into the realm of home appliances,
当我去了体育健身历史学家、新学院教授娜塔莉亚·梅尔曼·佩特拉泽拉的家时，她有足够多的重量让我们俩一起锻炼。这个是20磅。这个是35磅。那个是15磅，好吗？佩特拉泽拉教授在举重方面彻底打败了我，因为这只是她家和她生活的一部分。她有这些重量，并且经常举它们。健身器材和配件已经成为家用电器的经典，
especially during the pandemic. With with home fitness equipment, what people are willing to spend has only gotten higher and higher. And I think that's in part because we sacri-lyse exercise as a legitimate expanse in the legitimate pursuit and then just from the built environment of the home, or something desirable to show off. Through the past 30 or so years, home workout machines have all but promised to move your limbs for you. The Nordic track, the Beauflex, the Peloton. Maybe the Wii Fit, I don't know. But what Professor Petrazella gave me to hold while we did squats?
特别是在疫情期间。对于家用健身器材，人们愿意支付的价格只会越来越高。我认为这在一定程度上是因为我们将锻炼神圣化为一种合法的支出和追求，然后从家庭的建筑环境来看，它也成了某种值得炫耀的东西。在过去30年左右的时间里，家用健身器械几乎都承诺为你移动肢体。NordicTrack、Bowflex、Peloton。也许还有Wii Fit，我不知道。但佩特拉泽拉教授让我们在做深蹲时拿着什么？
A 35 pound iron kettlebell. It's about as low tech and simple as it gets. Fitness trends come and go, but the weight is an anchor in the shifting tides. There have been very few changes to its design. Russian farmers used kettlebells in the 1700s as counterweights to measure out grain. Barbells used to have those giant globes on either side of them that circus strongmen used to lift, and those were filled with sand or iron shot to modify the weight. But once barbells became erod with changeable solid iron plates, that was sort of that.
一个35磅的铁壶铃。它尽可能地低科技且简单。健身潮流来来去去，但重量是变幻潮汐中的锚。它的设计几乎没有什么变化。18世纪的俄罗斯农民使用壶铃作为称量谷物的配重。杠铃过去在两端有巨大的球体，马戏团大力士用它们来举重，里面装满了沙子或铁砂来调节重量。但一旦杠铃演变成带有可更换实心铁片的样式，基本上就是这样了。
35 pounds of iron is 35 pounds of iron. It's just that the culture around weights, who lifts them and why, has changed. If you look at the larger history of fitness culture in America, you have, at some moments, a kind of celebration of strength and muscle building in another moment, like a real ambivalence and even disgust about and fear
35磅的铁就是35磅的铁。只是围绕重量的文化，谁在举它们以及为什么举，已经发生了变化。如果你审视美国健身文化更宏大的历史，你会发现，在某些时刻，人们对力量和肌肉增长有一种庆祝，而在另一个时刻，却有一种真正的矛盾心理，甚至是对……的厌恶和恐惧。
about what it means to lift weights. Professor Petrazella is truly not exaggerating about the disgust and the fear. In the early part of the 20th century, there were honest to God health concerns around lifting weights. A widespread idea promoted even by doctors was that lifting weights would make you muscle bound. Muscle bound there being meant being literally about bonded by your muscles, like your brain
关于举重意味着什么。佩特拉泽拉教授对于这种厌恶和恐惧确实没有夸大。在20世纪早期，关于举重确实存在真正的健康担忧。甚至连医生都推广过一种广泛的观点，即举重会让你变得“肌肉僵硬”（muscle bound）。这里的“肌肉僵硬”是指被你的肌肉束缚住了，就像你的大脑，
wouldn't work, you were trapped by your muscles. And you couldn't touch your toes or touch your head, you'd be locked in a puffy muscular cage of your own making. And so the people who did venture into the world of weightlifting were not too forthcoming about it. Very unlike today, going to the gym, being seen exercising is not something that displays your virtue. Weightlifting as a subculture was sweaty and dirty and entirely suspicious. It was considered a form of body modification
无法正常工作，你被自己的肌肉困住了。你无法触碰脚趾或头部，你会被锁在自己制造的肿胀肌肉笼子里。所以那些冒险进入举重世界的人并不太愿意公开这一点。与今天完全不同，去健身房、被看到在锻炼并不是一种展示你美德的行为。作为亚文化的举重是汗流浃背、肮脏且完全令人怀疑的。它被认为是一种身体改造，
to coax your muscles to this dangerous, artificial edge with weights. And so it's easy to be like, haha, old timey people, why were they so scared of weights? I mean, I don't live weights. I think some of the reason why is because I'm intimidated. Not that I think weights would make me like unable to touch my head, I'm just, you know,
用重量诱导你的肌肉达到这种危险的、人为的边缘。所以很容易说，哈哈，老古董们，他们为什么那么害怕重量？我的意思是，我不举重。我想部分原因是因为我感到畏惧。并不是说我认为重量会让我无法触碰头部，我只是，你知道，
why would I want to get ripped? But in thinking about this eternal, unchangeable piece of equipment at the center of so many changing attitudes and fads around personal fitness in America, I came across the story of this one businessman who was arguably sort of a proto-home fitness guru from the 1930s.
我为什么要练得那么壮？但在思考这件处于美国个人健身不断变化的观念和时尚中心、永恒且不可改变的设备时，我偶然发现了这个商人的故事，他可以说是20世纪30年代某种原始的家庭健身大师。
And his entire vision was to get everyone to lift weights, no matter gender or age or race, back when no one believed that it was healthy. And I don't actually know if I could say he succeeded or not, because it's only fairly recently that we are finally sort of living in the reality that this guy envisioned, but it didn't happen until way long after his death
他的全部愿景是让每个人都去举重，无论性别、年龄或种族，在那个没人相信这有益健康的年代。我其实不知道他是否成功了，因为直到最近我们才终于生活在他所设想的现实中，但这发生在他去世很久之后，
and only in this very roundabout way. Oh, and his name is Bob Hoffman. Can you read it? Yes. At one time, I stood alone. I was almost the only believer in weight training for athletes. Now there are thousands of coaches who are teaching weight training to their teams and hundreds of thousands of athletes improving their athletic ability through weight training. Bob Hoffman.
而且是以这种非常迂回的方式。哦，他的名字叫鲍勃·霍夫曼。你能读出来吗？是的。“曾经，我孤身一人。我几乎是唯一相信运动员进行重量训练的人。现在有成千上万的教练在教他们的团队进行重量训练，成千上万的运动员通过重量训练提高了他们的运动能力。”——鲍勃·霍夫曼。
That quote from Bob Huffman is on a plaque at the entry of the weightlifting hall of fame in York, Pennsylvania, which is in a lot of ways a shrine to Bob Huffman. That's Bob. That's Bob. Yeah, Bob Lee. Jan Dellinger was my guide at the weightlifting Hall of Fame, where, out front, there is a seven-foot-tall bronze statue of Bob, gleaming, bald, shirtless, super ripped. Inside the atrium, there's another bust of Bob, his buff arms crossed proudly over his chest,
鲍勃·霍夫曼的那句名言刻在宾夕法尼亚州约克市举重名人堂入口处的牌匾上，在很多方面，这里是鲍勃·霍夫曼的圣地。那是鲍勃。那是鲍勃。是的，鲍勃·李。简·戴林格是我的向导，在举重名人堂，前面有一座七英尺高的鲍勃青铜雕像，闪闪发光，秃头，赤裸上身，超级强壮。在中庭里面，还有另一个鲍勃的半身像，他那强壮的手臂自豪地交叉在胸前，
and then right up there on the wall, there's a massive seepia photograph of Bob from the waist up in a frilly shirt, bow tie, and shiny patterns tuxedo, decorated with military medals. We all think he had a lot of medals. He just wore medals around. How do I talk about this? Tell me, okay, he had a big ego. He sometimes wore medals on his coat.
然后就在墙上，有一张巨大的棕褐色照片，是鲍勃的上半身，穿着褶边衬衫、领结和闪亮的燕尾服，装饰着军事勋章。我们都认为他有很多勋章。他只是到处戴着勋章。我该怎么说这个？告诉我，好吧，他虚荣心很强。他有时会在外套上戴勋章。
He sort of looked like a third-world general. Some of those were bought. Some of those, some of those he actually earned. Okay, so Bob Hoffman was actually a decorated World War I hero, but he had a knack for, shall we say, pumping up the truth about himself in particular. He was very egocentric, and I would say more so than 90% of people. When historian John Fair wrote the definitive biography of Bob Hoffman, it involved a lot of fact-checking. But Bob's very hearty ego turned out
他看起来有点像第三世界的将军。其中一些是买来的。其中一些，其中一些是他真正赢得的。好吧，鲍勃·霍夫曼确实是一位获得勋章的一战英雄，但他有一种诀窍，我们姑且称之为夸大关于他自己的事实。他非常以自我为中心，我想比90%的人都更甚。当历史学家约翰·费尔撰写鲍勃·霍夫曼的权威传记时，涉及了大量的核实工作。但鲍勃那颗非常强健的虚荣心，事实证明，
to be a useful tool for selling weightlifting to an incredulous American public in the 1930s. Because very few people believed in Barbados. Because, again, really, there was this concern that if you got too muscular, you'd ruin your body. And muscles would make athletes slow and inflexible. Football coaches were the worst. Oh my gosh, yes. And I played tennis in college, and the tennis coach told us, you, I don't want any of you guys ever touching barbells. Bob Hoffman had always been a good athlete.
是向20世纪30年代持怀疑态度的美国公众推销举重的有用工具。因为很少有人相信杠铃。因为，再说一次，确实存在一种担忧，即如果你肌肉太发达，你会毁掉你的身体。肌肉会让运动员变得缓慢且不灵活。橄榄球教练是最糟糕的。哦，天哪，是的。我在大学里打网球，网球教练告诉我们，你们，我不希望你们任何人碰杠铃。鲍勃·霍夫曼一直是个优秀的运动员。
He was a canoeur and a boxer. And when he began working out with barbells, his friends ridiculed him for seeking manufactured bumps. But he discovered that the strength of muscle gain from weightlifting made him better at sports. He realized from his personal experience that they helped him grow big and strong back in his canoeing days.
他是个皮划艇运动员和拳击手。当他开始用杠铃锻炼时，他的朋友们嘲笑他追求人造的隆起。但他发现举重带来的肌肉力量使他在运动中表现更好。他从个人经验中意识到，它们帮助他在皮划艇时代变得又大又强。
But Bob Hoffman was able to ascend into so much more than another secret gym rat. Because Bob co-founded a business that manufactured and sold oil burners. And in 1922, iron oil burners were a hot commodity. He got in on good thing. Oil burners were new. And everybody else had coal furnaces or fireplaces. York oil burners, based in York, Pennsylvania,
但鲍勃·霍夫曼能够晋升为不仅仅是另一个秘密健身狂。因为鲍勃共同创立了一家制造和销售燃油燃烧器的企业。在1922年，铁制燃油燃烧器是热门商品。他赶上了好时机。燃油燃烧器是新事物。而其他人都有煤炉或壁炉。位于宾夕法尼亚州约克的约克燃油燃烧器公司，
was doing pretty steady business, especially careening into the depression. And so Bob Hoffman was at liberty to hire anyone he wanted to. And he wanted to hire fellow weight lifters. Not only because he knew that buff dudes are good on the factory floor, but he also wanted to create his own community, to train together, and to engage in some friendly lifting competition.
生意一直很稳定，尤其是在大萧条时期。所以鲍勃·霍夫曼可以自由地雇佣他想要的任何人。他想雇佣其他的举重运动员。不仅因为他知道强壮的家伙在工厂车间表现出色，他还想建立自己的社区，一起训练，并进行一些友好的举重比赛。
And then Bob realized the process of iron casting that they used for oil burners could also make barbells, like just to have them to use for themselves for their training. They started manufacturing them there in the middle of the oil burner company and began recruiting weight lifters for around the area to work in the oil burner company, which is a really original idea. He gave people jobs. And so Bob assembled a team of his employees, of all races, of all backgrounds, brought to York, Pennsylvania from all over the country to form the York Oil Burner Athletic Club. Which has a very awkward name.
然后鲍勃意识到他们用于燃油燃烧器的铁铸造工艺也可以制造杠铃，就像只是为了他们自己训练使用一样。他们开始在那里，在燃油燃烧器公司中间制造它们，并开始招募该地区的举重运动员到燃油燃烧器公司工作，这是一个非常有创意的想法。他给了人们工作。于是鲍勃组建了一支由他的员工组成的团队，来自各种种族、各种背景，从全国各地带到宾夕法尼亚州约克，组成了约克燃油燃烧器运动俱乐部。这个名字非常尴尬。
And things ratcheted up very quickly from there. Because in the small but passionate world of competitive weightlifting, winning a regional meet could qualify you for the Olympics. And soon, members of the York Oil Burner Athletic Club were taking off to compete in the Olympics and all other kinds of international lifting competitions. Bob sent spent, I like $20 to send a telegram to Adolf Hitler, which was like basically in your face, you know. That was after a 1938 world championship.
从那以后事情发展得非常快。因为在竞争激烈的举重这个小而热情的圈子里，赢得地区比赛就有资格参加奥运会。很快，约克燃油燃烧器运动俱乐部的成员们就出发去参加奥运会和各种其他国际举重比赛了。鲍勃花了，我记得是20美元给阿道夫·希特勒发了一封电报，这基本上就是当面挑衅，你知道。那是在1938年世界锦标赛之后。
As Bob saw it, his Ragtag crew of guys, most of whom were blue collar and immigrants, were suddenly representing America. They were beating government-sponsored teams from fascist and communist countries. And this nationalism angle became a really important dimension for Bob Hoffman. He was fighting for America. He was fighting for our side. And Bob came to believe that everyone should be super excited about what he was accomplishing. I mean, Bob was basically funding and creating the American lifting team himself out of his
在鲍勃看来，他那群乌合之众，大多数是蓝领和移民，突然代表了美国。他们正在击败来自法西斯和共产主义国家的政府资助团队。这种民族主义角度对鲍勃·霍夫曼来说成了一个非常重要的维度。他在为美国而战。他在为我们这一方而战。鲍勃开始相信每个人都应该对他所取得的成就感到超级兴奋。我的意思是，鲍勃基本上是在亲自资助和创建美国举重队，
guys from the York Oil Burner Athletic Club. You're welcome, America. And so if Bob Hoffman was going to get the appreciation he thought he deserved, he needed to get rid of the stigma around lifting weights to get Americans to embrace the barbell and to understand the beauty of lifting. And not only for his employees slash Olympic champions, but so that every single American could be healthy and strong and, you know, prepared just in case one of those nations with a state sponsored lifting
成员来自他的约克燃油燃烧器运动俱乐部。不客气，美国。所以如果鲍勃·霍夫曼要获得他认为自己应得的赞赏，他就需要消除围绕举重的污名，让美国人拥抱杠铃，并理解举重的美感。不仅是为了他的员工兼奥运冠军，而且是为了让每一个美国人都能健康强壮，并且，你知道，以防万一那些拥有国家资助举重队的国家试图入侵我们。他对抗的是整个国家，而且他们在很大程度上是出于意识形态目的。所以是的，他面对的是一堵巨大的石墙，他无法克服自己。早在1932年，鲍勃就在燃油燃烧器公司创办了一本名为《力量与健康》的杂志。在社论中，鲍勃警告说美国生活太安逸了。“绝大多数人都是软弱的。”而且，为了避免我们的国家被入侵，我们必须强大。这本杂志里塞满了操作指南、建议和奥运冠军的励志封面照片，其中许多人恰好是鲍勃在约克的员工。1935年，当美国最大的杠铃公司Milo Barbell破产时，鲍勃
team tried to invade us. It was entire nations he was working against and they were doing it for to a great extent ideological purposes. So yeah he was up against a big stone wall and he couldn't get over himself. Back in 1932, Bob had started a magazine out of the oil burner company called Strength and Health. In editorials, Bob warned that American life was too easy. The vast majority of the people are soft. And that, to avoid having our own country invaded, we must be strong. The magazine was packed with how to's and advice and inspirational cover photos of Olympic champions, many of whom just so happen to be Bob's employees at York. And in 1935, when Milo Barbell, America's biggest barbell company, went bankrupt, Bob
买下了它。我们正处于大萧条时期，鲍勃在大萧条时期买下了一家邮购杠铃业务。这就是鲍勃的推销能力。到20世纪30年代末，鲍勃·霍夫曼已经完全放弃了燃油燃烧器业务，开始全职制造和销售杠铃。约克燃油燃烧器现在变成了约克杠铃公司，当你想到燃油燃烧器曾经多么受欢迎，而重量曾经多么令人怀疑和冷门时，这真是一个巨大的飞跃。
bought it. We're in the middle of the depression and Bob's buying a mail order barbell business in the middle of the depression. That's how much of a sell it Bob was. By the late 1930s, Bob Hoffman had ditched the oil burner business entirely and started manufacturing and selling barbells full time. York oil burner had now become York barbell company, which is quite the leap when you think about how popular oil burners were and how suspicious and niche weights were.
所以鲍勃有很多说服工作要做。约克多年来在30年代举办了许多展览，他们会去嘉年华并进行表演。鲍勃利用他的奥运团队兼员工作为模特和代言人来销售他的重量和家庭锻炼课程。约克男人们和鲍勃·霍夫曼开着一辆敞篷跑车在全国各地旅行，车前绑着一个杠铃。他们会举起杠铃，然后用手肘触碰脚趾，以展示他们依然多么灵活。这是关键。约克男人们展示的举重风格。鲍勃最崇拜的风格是奥林匹克举重。确实，这就是奥运会中的举重风格。但除此之外，它是一种非常具体的
So Bob had a lot of convincing to do. York gave a lot of exhibitions over the years back into 30s and they would go to carnivals and have shows. Bob used his Olympic team slash employees as models and spokesmen to sell his weights and home workout courses. The York men and Bob Hoffman traveled all over the country in a roadster with a barbell strap to the front. They would lift the barbell and then touch their elbows to their toes to show how flexible they still were. And this is key. The style of lift that the York men were demonstrating. The style that Bob most adored was Olympic lifting. Indeed, this is the style of lifting that is in the Olympics. But aside from that, it is a very specific
风格，简单来说就是这样。它是举起一个杠铃，通过一系列编排好的动作，如抓举、挺举，将其举过头顶。这不仅仅是关于举起尽可能多的重量。这是关于你如何举起它。奥林匹克举重需要更多的爆发力、速度、协调性和灵活性。奥林匹克举重运动员很敏捷，甚至可以说很优雅。他们与“肌肉僵硬”恰恰相反。
style, which, put simply, is this. It is lifting a barbell and raising it over one's head, through a sequence of choreographed moves like the snatch, clean, and jerk. It's not just about lifting the most weight possible. It's about how you lift it. Olympic lifting takes a little more snap, speed, coordination, and flexibility. Olympic lifters were agile, and dare I say graceful. They were the opposite of muscle bound.
所以鲍勃真的希望每个人都对他的奥林匹克举重队感到兴奋，并且自己也在做奥林匹克举重。每个人，所有年龄段。是的，如果你再次接触到《力量与健康》文化，而鲍勃在很大程度上塑造了这种文化，你会找到支持。对于一个十几岁的男孩，你会看到一些和你同龄的孩子。简·戴林格实际上长大后在20世纪70年代在约克的编辑部门工作。
And so Bob really wanted everyone to be excited And dare I say graceful, they were the opposite of muscle bound. And so Bob really wanted everyone to be excited about his Olympic lifting team and to be doing Olympic lifting themselves. Everyone, all ages. Yeah, if you tapped into the strength and health culture again, which Bob was very much in forming, you found support. And for a teenage boy, you saw some kids your own age. Jan Dallinger actually grew up to work in the editorial arm of York in the 1970s.
但即使在那之前，《力量与健康》有一个由女性为女性撰写的专栏，名为“杠铃”，关于举重如何帮助你保持苗条的身材。阅读《力量与健康》是一种在神秘、可怕的健身房之外的社区形式。事实上，鲍勃·霍夫曼认为这是锻炼的更好方式。他写道：“家庭训练是产生最大肌肉力量和增长的最佳方式。”再说一次，这是一个疯狂的提议。当你想到简向他父亲要求重量以便在家锻炼时得到的反应。
But even before that, strengthen health had a column written for women by women called barbells about how lifting can help you keep a trim physique. Reading strengthen health was a form of community outside the realm of mysterious scary gyms. And actually Bob Hoffman thought that was a better way to work out. He wrote, Home training is the best way to produce the maximum in muscular strength and growth. And again, this was a wild proposition. When you think about the reaction, Jan got from his dad when he asked for weight so he could work out at home.
“我爸爸大发雷霆。”是的，大发雷霆。他说：“我们不会为你买那些东西。”所以你可以说，哇，鲍勃·霍夫曼很有先见之明。这太神奇了。他是怎么知道重量对你有好处的？答案是，他不知道。他有点凭直觉行事。我想你会说这都是试错，但它似乎奏效了。而且更重要的是，他赚了很多钱。因为在某个时候，鲍勃变得像个马乔·瓜尼思·帕乔（macho guanith palcho）。他开始疯狂地出版书籍和更多杂志，里面充满了各种建议，延伸到举重之外的全面健康。
My dad threw a fit. Yes, threw a fit. He said, we're not buying news for you. So you could be like, wow, Bob Hoffman was pretty prescient. That's amazing. How did he know that wait's are good for you? The answer was, he didn't. He was kind of shooting from the hip. It was all sort of trial and error, I guess you would say, but it seemed to be working. And once more, he was making a lot of money. Because at a certain point, Bob becomes like a macho guanith palcho. He starts cranking up books and more magazines full of all kinds of advice that extend beyond weightlifting into general wellness.
其中一些建议简直就是，等等，什么？没人回到一千，但我就是鲍勃的难题。鲍勃是个难题。在鲍勃1938年的书《如何变得强壮、快乐和健康》中，在一页上他告诉人们避免吃白面粉和精制糖，这就像，好吧，哇，说得很对。但随后你翻过那一页，他告诉人们避免吃白面粉和精制糖，这就像，好吧，哇，说得很对。
And some of this advice is just like, wait, what? Nobody's back in a thousand, but I'm the eye that Bob's conundrum. Bob is a conundrum. In Bob's 1938 book, How to Be Strong, Happy and Healthy, on one page he's telling people to avoid eating white flour and refined sugar, which is like, okay, wow, pretty on the nose there. But then you turn the page one page he's telling people to avoid eating white flour and refined sugar, which is like, okay, wow, pretty on the nose there.
但随后你翻过那一页，他说大多数头痛是由便秘引起的，不要在食物上加调味品，手淫会削弱一个人的力量。关于鲍勃的规则，有些确实有道理。通常他认为它们并不适用于他个人。他在印刷品中抨击咖啡因和咖啡之类的东西，但他自己却服用。他有点咖啡因狂。真的吗？是的。他不会让他的
But then you turn the page and he's saying, most headaches are caused by constipation and not to put condiments on your food and that masturbation can sap a man's strength. And the thing about Bob's rules that did have merit. Oftentimes he thought they did not personally apply to him. He railed in print against caffeine and coffee and stuff, but he took no dose. He was kind of caffeine-freak. Really? Yeah. He would not have mounted his
男孩们喝咖啡。那是喝咖啡。在一个人的脑海里有这种分离。别让我解释。我可能说得太多了。鲍勃建议保证八小时的睡眠，但说他个人不需要，因为——“我比大多数人睡得快。”任何人想要完全按照鲍勃·霍夫曼设定的规则生活都很困难，包括鲍勃·霍夫曼自己。
boys for like drinking coffee. That's drinking coffee. There's separation there in one person's mind. Don't ask me to explain it. I'm probably telling you more, I should. Bob advised a solid eight hours of sleep, but said that he personally didn't need it because- I sleep faster than most people. It would be hard for anyone to live entirely by the rules Bob Hoffman set, including Bob Hoffman.
他喜欢热狗。他喜欢汉迪。他用不健康的食物放纵自己。他声称自己是世界上最健康的人，但结果却是世界上最不健康的人之一。所以鲍勃是一个完全的混合体，有很多矛盾的、毫无根据的或无法遵循的建议，这使得他在举重方面100%正确显得非常疯狂。但随后让我觉得搞笑的部分是，这个有点坏掉的时钟最终两次都对了，因为鲍勃又凭直觉推出了另一个健身产品。而且再一次，他击中了目标。如果你想变得强壮健康，你需要更多的蛋白质。这就像，他是导致我可以去便利店买蛋白棒的原因吗？他绝对普及了这个想法。1952年，鲍勃推出了一种他称为“High Protein”的产品，拼写有两个E。配方基本上是从一位曾经的商业伙伴那里偷来的，基本上就是他与附近宾夕法尼亚州赫尔希的巧克力混合的大豆粉。他亲自
He loved hot dogs. He loved handy. He indulged himself with unhealthy food. He claimed to be the healthiest man in the world, but he turned out to be one of the unhealthiest men in the world. So Bob was a total mixed bag with a lot of contradictory or unfounded or unfollowable advice, which makes it wild that he was 100% correct about weightlifting. But then the hilarious part to
用独木舟桨在一个巨大的桶里非常不科学地混合它。鲍勃在那里汗流浃背地制作“High Protein”，最终让其他人来做这种汗流浃背的工作。他用同样的混合物来销售他的增重产品，就像他销售减重产品一样。哦，天哪，不，它们是完全相同的产品。完全一样。相同的产品。他坚持认为这些高蛋白产品是美国举重运动员在20世纪50年代如此成功的原因。所以最终鲍勃·霍夫曼创造了这个循环，他想让美国人对他的奥运团队感到兴奋，通过基本上依赖他的奥运团队来销售他的出版物
me is that this somewhat broken clock ends up being right twice, because Bob shot from the hip again with another fitness product. And again, he hits the target. If you want to be strong and healthy, you need more protein. It's like, is he the reason I can go get protein bars at the bodega? He definitely popularized the idea. In 1952, Bob introduced a product he called high protein, spelled with two E's. The recipe was essentially stolen from a one-time business partner, and it was basically soybean powder that he mixed with chocolate from nearby Hershey, Pennsylvania. And he personally
和蛋白质产品以及重量。但随着个人、专业运动队和教练开始购买和使用约克杠铃和“High Protein”，它使举重成为达到目的的手段，而不是目的本身。因为事实证明，鲍勃的客户并不一定对学习奥林匹克举重的编排和运动感兴趣，为了美国的伟大荣耀。他们甚至不一定对为了其他运动而进行举重训练感兴趣。事实证明，鲍勃相当大一部分客户，
mixed it himself very unscientificly in a giant vat with a canoe paddle. Bob was in there sweating away, making high protein, eventually got others to do this sweating away. He was using the same mixture to sell his gain weight product, as he was to sell his loose weight product. Oh my God, no, they were the exact same product. Exactly. The same product. He insisted that these high protein products were the reason that American weightlifters were so successful in the 1950s. So ultimately Bob Hoffman had created this loop where he wanted to get Americans excited about his Olympic team by essentially relying on his Olympic team to sell his publications
可能比鲍勃意识到的还要大，只是想要结果。这就是年轻男性最想要的，看起来强壮并给别人留下深刻印象。而且，是的，拥有力量很好，但外表是主要的事情。问题变成了，什么样的外表是想要的外表？重量如何融入其中？休息后，对约克帝国的意识形态挑战将东海岸与西海岸、竞技与美学对立起来。并最终带我们了解你今天可能在家做的锻炼。
and protein products and weights. But as individuals and professional sports teams and trainers started buying and using York barbells and high protein, it made lifting weights a means to an end and not an end itself. Because it turned out Bob's customers were not necessarily interested in learning the choreography and sport of Olympic lifting for the Great Glory of America. They weren't even necessarily interested in lifting to train for other sports. Turned out a sizable portion of Bob's customers,
竞争的真理在于它往往源于钦佩。所以残酷的讽刺是，那个挑战约克杠铃统治地位的举重大师本可以很容易成为鲍勃·霍夫曼的门徒。因为当鲍勃在约克建立他的帝国时，一个叫乔·韦德的孩子在蒙特利尔家里迷上了举重。据简·戴林格说，乔·韦德贪婪地吸收了鲍勃所做的一切。他是《力量与健康》的忠实读者和约克杠铃的举重者。好吧，这里有一件事人们不知道。
maybe more sizable than Bob realized, just wanted results. That's what young men want most of all is to look big and to impress people. And it doesn't, yeah, that's good to have strength, but appearance is the main thing. And the question became, what kind of appearance is the appearance to want? And how do weights fit into that? After the break, an ideological challenge to the York Empire pits the East Coast against the West Coast, athletics versus aesthetics. And ultimately gets us to the kind of workouts you might be doing at home today.
当韦德在30年代末开始时，他是约克的代表。他代理，他代理。约克杠铃的东西。如果你还记得约翰·费尔对鲍勃·霍夫曼的描述，他非常以自我为中心。而且我想说比90%的人都更甚。这是句子的后半部分。但他在这个体育文化领域有他的对手，因为乔·韦德也是一样。乔·韦德还是个十几岁的少年时就开始建立他的举重帝国。传说他掠夺了旧版的《力量与健康》来获取联系信息，
The truism of rivalry is that it often springs from admiration. And so the cruel irony is that the weightlifting guru who emerged to challenge the reign of York Barbell could have easily been Bob Hoffman's protege. Because while Bob was building his empire in York, a kid named Joe Weeder was home in Montreal getting hooked on weightlifting. And according to Jan Dellinger, Joe Weeder gobbled up everything Bob did. He was a devoted reader of strength and health and a lifter of York barbells. Okay, here's something people don't know.
大约600名加拿大肌肉男，并给他们每人寄了一张明信片，鼓励他们订阅他的出版物，结果证明是听起来非常有法裔加拿大风格的《你的体格》（Your Physique）。第一期出版于1940年，当时乔只有19岁。最终，当约克因为关税增加而停止在加拿大销售重量时，乔·韦德决定通过制造自己的重量来填补空白。最终，他也开始兜售蛋白质。韦德看到鲍勃从中赚了很多钱，所以他开始制造
When Weeder started out in the late 30s, he was a York rep. He rep, he rep. York Barbell stuff. And if you recall John Faire's description of Bob Hoffman, he was very egocentric. And I would say more so than 90% of people. Here's the rest of the sentence. But he had his equal in this field of physical culture, because Joe Weeder was the same way. Joe Weeder was still a teenager when he began to build his weightlifting empire. Legend has it, he pillaged old editions of strength and health to get the contact information of
他自己的蛋白质，他称之为“High Protein”，拼写不同。韦德正确地拼写了“protein”。然后韦德在制造韦德维生素矿物质补充剂、韦德能量片、韦德减重辅助补充剂、韦德增重补充剂。韦德基本上是在把补充剂作为一种神奇的捷径来销售，帮助你获得锻炼的好处而无需流汗。这是乔·韦德和鲍勃·霍夫曼之间重要区别的一部分。乔不在乎能否像奥林匹克举重运动员那样执行挺举，
about 600 Canadian musclemen and mailed them each a postcard encouraging them to sign up for his publication, which turned out to be the extremely French Canadian sounding, your physique. The first issue came out in 1940, when Joe was only 19 years old. And eventually, when York stopped selling weights in Canada because of a tariff increase, Joe Weeder decided to fill the gap by manufacturing his own weights. And eventually, he got into shilling protein, too. Weeder saw that Bob was making a lot of money out of it, and so he started manufacturing
他的《你的体格》读者也不在乎。他们不想读关于精确的奥林匹克编排或如何出于某种爱国义务而保持健康。他们只是想要肌肉。所以如果你想出名并赚很多钱，你去哪里？
his own protein, and he caught it high protein and spelled it differently. Weeder spelled protein correctly. And then Weeder was making Weeder vitamin mineral supplement, Weeder energy tablets, Weeder reduced aid supplement, Weeder weight gaining supplement. Weeder was essentially selling supplements as a magical shortcut to help you glean the benefits of working out without breaking a sweat. And this is part of an important distinction between Joe Weeter and Bob Hoffman. Joe did not care about being able to execute a clean and jerk like an Olympic weightlifter
韦德真的做对了。他推断是在健美运动中。所以这就是我们大举进军的方向。那是为了巨大隆起的肌肉。健美运动是这样一种理念：你可以精确地雕刻你的三角肌和肱三头肌，把自己变成你自己设计的雕像。这与其说是关于竞技，不如说是关于美学。你这样做不是为了你的国家，而是为了你自己。我想你会说这是自利，你成为了一个韦德人。韦德方式和霍夫曼方式本质上是两种不同的哲学，即使他们使用的是相同的
did. And neither did his readers of your physique. They didn't want to read about precise Olympic choreography or how to be fit out of some a clean and jerk like an Olympic weightlifter did. And neither did his readers of your physique. They didn't want to read about precise Olympic choreography or how to be fit out of some patriotic duty. They just wanted muscles. So where do you go if you want to become famous and make a lot of money?
重量。在1945年6月的约克杠铃俱乐部野餐会上，宾夕法尼亚州约克市首次被称为“美国肌肉之城”。鲍勃的诺曼·洛克威尔式的美国梦，为蓝领工人们在工作内外一起生活和哼哼，所有人都顺从地按照鲍勃严格的健康和保健规则生活，以便通过奥林匹克举重的纪律为美国带回荣耀。但健美运动在洛杉矶已经开始升温，这就是韦德最终会搬去并建立基地的地方。肌肉海滩在20世纪30年代作为体操运动员和杂技演员练习的地点出现。肌肉海滩，在那里你展示你拥有的任何东西。
And we'd really got it right. He reasoned that it's in bodybuilding. So that's what we were going for in a big way. That's for big bulging muscles. Bodybuilding is the idea that you can sculpt your deltoids and your triceps just so and make yourself into a statue of your own design. It was less about athletics and more about aesthetics. That you're doing this not so much for your country, but you're doing this for yourself. I guess you would say self-interest, that you become a weeder man. The weeder way and the Hoffman way were just fundamentally two different philosophies, even if they were using the same
到了20世纪50年代，这片木板路吸引了演员、临时演员、特技替身和健身爱好者，男人和一些女人去阳光下锻炼。游客们来看他们美丽、完美晒黑的身体，他们微笑着表演后空翻，堆叠成人体金字塔。这是一种身体意识文化。我的意思是，无论你是做体操、手倒立还是举重健美，无论什么。南加州那里就是一种波西米亚氛围。对鲍勃·霍夫曼来说，这个肌肉海滩场景看起来就像自恋的棉花糖。
weights. At the York Barbell Club picnic in June of 1945, York, Pennsylvania was first dubbed Muscle Town USA. Bob's Americana Norman Rockwellian mecca for blue collar workers living and grunting together on and off the clock, all obediently living by Bob's strict rules for health and wellness in order to bring glory back to the United States through the discipline of Olympic lifting. But the bodybuilding movement had been gathering steam in Los Angeles, and this is where weeder would eventually move and set up shop. Muscle Beach had popped up in the 1930s as a spot for gymnasts and acrobats to practice. Muscle beach, where you flex whatever you have.
《力量与健康》反复嘲讽那些为了肌肉而要肌肉的健美者。很快，鲍勃创造了“明智的身体训练”一词，以区分他那运动的、健康的约克方式。与他所看到的乔·韦德肤浅的方式区分开来。他基本上把乔·韦德拖入了一场他们出版物之间持续的战争。我采访过的个人有点责怪鲍勃引发了这场争斗，因为鲍勃是领跑者，他不喜欢来自这个暴发户、这个加拿大人、这个受到共产主义影响或鼓励共产主义思想的外国人的竞争。
And by the 1950s, this slice of boardwalk attracted actors and extras and stunt doubles and workout buffs, men and some women who went to exercise in the sun. Tourists came to gawk at their beautiful, perfectly-sunt-hand bodies as they smiled and performed flips and stacked in human pyramids. It was a body conscious culture. I mean, whether you were doing gymnastics or hand-balancing or lifting a body building, whatever. It was just like a Bohemian atmosphere there in Southern California. To Bob Hoffman, this muscle-beach scene just looked like narcissistic cotton candy.
这简直是笑话，但鲍勃和乔之间的争斗最终变得非常丑陋和琐碎，就像互相攻击对方的离婚和财务状况，甚至连好文章都算不上。我的意思是，这几乎是……。这很疯狂，因为健美和奥林匹克举重过去有很多重叠。约克的许多奥林匹克举重运动员
Repeatedly, strengthen health-smirred- Boobie builders who wanted muscles for muscle-sake. Soon, Bob coined the term sensible physical training to differentiate his athletic, healthy York way. From what he saw as Joe Weeter's superficial way. He essentially dragged Joe Weeter into an ongoing war between their publications. Individuals that I've interviewed sort of blame Bob for the feud, because Bob was the front runner, and he didn't like this competition from this upstart, this Canadian, and this foreigner who was under communist influence or encouraging
过去也称自己为健美运动员。但当这种裂痕打开时，许多约克人倒戈成为了韦德人。此外，许多人因为低工资和糟糕的管理离开了约克。毕竟，为什么你想在鲍勃不可能的生活规则下生活，并在杠铃业务和奥运团队中为他工作
communist ideas. Which is like Loll, but the feud between Bob and Joe eventually got truly very ugly and petty, just like firing shots about each other's divorces and finances, stuff that didn't even make good articles. I mean, it's almost seconding. Which is wild because bodybuilding and Olympic lifting used to have a lot of overlap. A lot of the Olympic lifters at York
在宾夕法尼亚州中部，当你可以在肌肉海滩的阳光下锻炼并在环球先生比赛中摆姿势时？在乔·韦德将一位年轻的奥地利举重运动员纳入麾下后，健美生活方式更具吸引力。1968年，他来到了美国。施瓦辛格是韦德的产品，你知道。施瓦辛格改变了整个游戏规则，不仅对举重运动员，而且对更广泛的美国公众，当他们看到阿诺德主演电影时。
used to also call themselves bodybuilders. But when this rift opened, a number of York men defected to become Weedermen. Also, a lot of the guys just left York because of low wages and poor management. After all, why would you want to live under Bob's impossible lifestyle rules and work for him in both the Barbell business and on the Olympic team
我是海尔克·卡利兹。杠铃被几乎所有人接受，但这直到70年代才广泛发生。而且很可能是韦德获利最多，并最终取代了霍夫曼。鲍勃·霍夫曼对举重文化的影响是巨大的。他转化了许多运动队和军队成员开始使用重量，但最终鲍勃在情感和经济上放弃了奥运团队。奇怪的是，霍夫曼转而资助垒球队。而那个垒球的事情真的很奇怪。而美国在奥运会上的举重实际上从未完全恢复。
in Central Pennsylvania, when you could work out in the sun on Muscle Beach and pose in Mr. Universe competitions? And the bodybuilding lifestyle was all the more alluring after Joe Weeter took a young Austrian lifter under his wing. And in 1968, he had his way to the U.S. Mars Fortsinator was a Weeter product, you know. Schwartz and Eger changed the whole game, not just for lifters but for the wider American public when they saw Arnold star in movies.
自从鲍勃在60年代停止亲自资助它以来，去年算是一件大事，因为女子队的一名成员赢得了银牌，但女子队最后一次有人赢得金牌是在20年前。而在男子队，情况尤其惨淡。男子队自1984年以来没有赢得过一枚奖牌。我甚至不知道美国人在举重方面有多糟糕，因为没人真正谈论它。好吧，我们不强调举重作为一项运动或奥林匹克运动。
I'm Hylke Kaliz. Barbells became accepted by virtually everyone, but it didn't happen until, widely, until the 70s. And it was probably weeder that cached in most, and eventually displaced Hoffman. Bob Hoffman's impact on the culture of weightlifting was and is huge. He converted a lot of sports teams and members of the military to start using weights, but ultimately Bob gave up on the Olympic team, emotionally and financially. Oddly Hoffman turned to funding softball teams. And that softball thing was really weird. And American lifting at the Olympics has actually never quite recovered.
其他国家这样做。所以是的，当举重在文化上变得可以接受时，它是为了健美和它的炫耀，而不是为了运动。有趣的是，佩特拉泽拉教授说，举重为美国健身的下一个大规模运动奠定了基础，那就是有氧运动。那么当有氧运动成为一件大事时会发生什么？好吧，多亏了这些力量和热情而酝酿的热情，现在有一种世界已经准备好的锻炼形式，它对你有好处，不涉及举重，
Pretty much ever since Bob stopped personally bankrolling it in the 60s, last year was kind of a big deal because a member of the women's team won a silver medal, but the last time someone on the women's team won a gold medal was 20 years ago. And on the men's team, it's been especially bleak. The men's team hasn't won a single medal since 1984. And I didn't even know how bad Americans were at lifting, because no one really talks about it. Well, we don't emphasize weightlifting as a sport or as an Olympic sport.
拿着东西，不涉及寄送这些你必须放在家里的沉重铁块。它可能只是在外面和街上小跑，你知道，穿着你的慢跑服和橡胶底鞋。有氧运动，始于60年代，但在80年代真正起飞，就像通往苗条、活力身体的万无一失、不吓人的方式。健美操、游泳和水中有氧运动随之而来，问题是，到了80年代，重量在文化上已经变得足够被接受，可以作为有氧家庭锻炼的一部分。
Other countries do this. So yeah, when weightlifting became culturally acceptable, it was for bodybuilding and the showiness of it rather than the sport. And interestingly, Professor Petrazella says that weightlifting set the stage for the next massive movement in American fitness, which was cardio. So what happens when cardio becomes a big deal? Well, the enthusiasm that has been percolating thanks to these like strength and enthusiasm, now there's a form of exercise that the world is primed for, that is good for you, that doesn't involve lifting,
如果你有几个重量，你可能想在这些第一个练习中使用较重的那个，肩部耸动。在这个80年代的简·方达锻炼视频中，她只是使用小金属哑铃，你可以听到健美运动的美学影响。你仍然可以听到与变得太强壮相关的恐惧。健美运动。你仍然可以听到与变得太强壮相关的恐惧。信息已经传达出来了。就像举重对你有好处，当然。但如果你不想变得肿胀，也许你应该只用小的。
having things, doesn't involve sending away for these iron, heavy weights that you have to have in your house. It could be just trotting around outside and in the street, you know, when you're jogging suit and you're like, rubber-sled shoes. Cardio, which started in the 60s, but really took off in the 80s, was like the surefire not scary way to a lean, life body. In comes aerobics and swimming and aqua aerobics, and the thing is, by the 80s, weights have become culturally accepted enough to be included as part of cardio home workouts.
拥有这些东西并不意味着非得去买那些沉重的铁制器械放在家里。你只需要穿着慢跑服和橡胶底运动鞋在户外或街上小跑就行了。有氧运动始于60年代，但在80年代真正流行起来，它被视为一种既稳妥又不会让人感到畏惧的瘦身方式。随后，健美操、游泳和水中健美操应运而生。关键在于，到了80年代，举重在文化上已被广泛接受，并被纳入了家庭有氧健身的一部分。
If you have several weights, you may want to use the heavier one for these first exercises, the shoulder shrugs. In this Jane Fonda workout video from the 80s where she's just using little metal dumbbells, you can hear the aesthetic influence of bodybuilding. You can also still hear the fear associated with getting too muscular. bodybuilding. You can also still hear the fear associated with getting too muscular. The message had come through. Like lifting weights was good for you, sure. But if you didn't want to get swollen, maybe you should just use little ones.
如果你有几个不同重量的哑铃，你可能想在做第一组练习——耸肩运动时使用较重的那一个。在这段80年代简·方达的健身视频中，她只用了小金属哑铃，你可以从中听到健美运动对审美的影响。你依然能感受到人们对练得过于强壮的恐惧。当时传达的信息是：举重对你有好处，这当然没错。但如果你不想练得太壮，或许还是用小重量的哑铃比较好。
This is a new version of that same old fear of muscle boundness. Weightlifting had always had this baggage with it, particularly for women, that it's unhealthy because it's heavy. There's a lot of that same kind of framing and marketing and reassurance about like, don't worry, it will make you thin or at least it won't make you bulky. And that's literally the same thing
这是对那种老旧的“肌肉僵硬”恐惧症的新版本。举重一直背负着这种包袱，尤其是对女性而言，认为它因为重量大而不健康。这种框架、营销和安慰的话术有很多，比如“别担心，它会让你变瘦，或者至少不会让你变得臃肿”。这和我们自20世纪40年代以来一直听到的话完全是一回事。
that we've been hearing since the 1940s. And this is of course gendered, but I don't think it's entirely gendered. I think there are also a lot of class hang-ups around what kind of bodies an intellectual in-the-knowledge economy should have, what it means to be lean and leisurely. Muscles carry a lot of baggage. So I've always been like, I don't really wanna lift that baggage up. And it turns out Professor Petrazella, at the same time as she was roundly kicking my ass with her workouts, told me that she used to be just as hesitant as I was.
当然，这带有性别色彩，但我认为并不完全是性别问题。我认为在知识经济中，知识分子应该拥有什么样的身体，什么是精干和悠闲，这些方面也存在很多阶级偏见。肌肉背负着沉重的包袱。所以我一直觉得，我不想去触碰那些包袱。结果发现，Petrazella教授在用她的训练让我吃尽苦头的同时，也告诉我她曾经和我一样犹豫不决。
I had totally incorporated the worldview that like, I build muscle easily and that's a problem. You know, and so I don't wanna bulk out. So here I'll take you to grab your right leg. Basically, in 2018, Professor Petrazella wanted to train for the New York Marathon, and a coach suggested that part of her training should be weightlifting, that it would make her faster and healthier and fitter. That cardio and real, full weight training can go together cohesively.
我完全接受了那种“我很容易长肌肉，这是个问题”的世界观。你知道，所以我不想变得臃肿。好了，现在我带你抓住你的右腿。基本上，在2018年，Petrazella教授想为纽约马拉松进行训练，一位教练建议她训练的一部分应该是举重，说这会让她跑得更快、更健康、体能更好。有氧运动和真正的全面重量训练是可以和谐共存的。
And this has been a fundamental tenend of a relatively recent movement in fitness. One that I actually did not realize was actively underway all around me. You have to be a 10 and 10! It's your love of America, right? Too much. CrossFit gyms are often in garages, or designed to look like gritty garages. Because that's where the movement began. It was invented for anyone to do in their home.
这是近期健身运动的一个基本信条。我之前甚至没有意识到它就在我身边如火如荼地进行着。你必须达到10分满分！这是你对美国的热爱，对吧？太多了。CrossFit健身房通常设在车库里，或者设计成粗犷的车库风格。因为运动就是从那里开始的。它是为每个人在家里就能做而发明的。
Because you're not working out with abstract work-out machines or trying to target specific body parts. You're working with different weights and ropes and things that might replicate real-world situations. If you had to quickly run somewhere or lift something. CrossFit is a polarizing program, but there's no question that after CrossFit came out in 2001, it spawned all of these different kinds of programs that put weight training at the center of fitness.
因为你不是在使用抽象的健身器械，也不是试图针对特定的身体部位进行锻炼。你是在使用不同的重量、绳索和可能模拟现实生活情况的物体。比如你需要快速跑向某处或举起某物。CrossFit是一个两极分化的项目，但毫无疑问，自2001年CrossFit出现以来，它催生了所有这些将重量训练作为健身核心的不同类型的项目。
CrossFit was the birth of the functional fitness movement. The idea of the functional fitness is that you'd only need one barbell and a few weights and you can do all these different kinds of things. Katie Rose, Heytmanek is a professor of culture and anthropology at Brooklyn College. And I'm an Olympic weightlifter. Indeed, the style of lifting that Bob Hoffman loved. Olympic weightlifting in the United States has boomed since the advent of CrossFit.
CrossFit是功能性健身运动的开端。功能性健身的理念是，你只需要一个杠铃和几个砝码，就可以做各种各样的动作。Katie Rose Heytmanek是布鲁克林学院的文化与人类学教授。而我是一名奥林匹克举重运动员。确实，Bob Hoffman所钟爱的正是这种举重风格。自CrossFit出现以来，美国的奥林匹克举重运动蓬勃发展。
Because CrossFit brought the weightlifting equipment and style and moves into an everyday class for like general populations. And the person responsible for CrossFit is in some ways a very Bob Hoffman-like figure. It was proposing weightlifting workouts for the masses. A rogue personal trainer named Greg Glassman. He got kind of kicked out of his mainstream gym because he was doing all kinds of stuff differently. Glassman would do ridiculous numbers of repetitions in a short time and then run around the block
因为CrossFit将举重设备、风格和动作带入了大众的日常课程中。而负责CrossFit的人在某种程度上是一个非常像Bob Hoffman的人物。他为大众提出了举重训练方案。一个名叫Greg Glassman的叛逆私人教练。他因为做事方式与众不同而被主流健身房赶了出来。Glassman会在短时间内做大量的重复动作，然后绕着街区跑步，
and then maybe do some gymnastics moves, maybe swing some their garages, until after September 11th. It is not coincidental. The only thing that's happening is that the world is in a state of chaos. The world is in a state of chaos. The world is in a state of chaos. The world is in a state of chaos. The world is in a state of chaos. The world is in a state of chaos. The world is in a state of chaos. So this was done mostly by rogue individuals in their garages until after September 11th.
然后可能做一些体操动作，可能在车库里挥舞一些东西，直到9月11日之后。这并非巧合。唯一发生的事情是世界处于混乱状态。世界处于混乱状态。世界处于混乱状态。世界处于混乱状态。世界处于混乱状态。世界处于混乱状态。世界处于混乱状态。所以这主要是由那些在车库里的叛逆个人完成的，直到9月11日之后。
It is not coincidental that the CrossFit, the Warontaire, the US military, and the Barbell sort of came up together. After 9-11, all the elements that had been weird and alienating about CrossFit, the accessibility, the intensity of it, suddenly this was really appealing to a civilian population who just bought gas masks and go bags because they wanted to be prepared for everything. And this was also appealing to a military gearing up to recruit for a new war. Paramilitarism was built into the very culture of CrossFit. CrossFit even started a line of workouts named after soldiers who died in the war on terror.
CrossFit、反恐战争、美军和杠铃几乎是同时出现的，这并非巧合。9-11事件后，CrossFit中所有那些怪异和疏离的元素——可及性、强度——突然对那些刚刚购买了防毒面具和应急包的平民来说非常有吸引力，因为他们想为一切做好准备。这也吸引了一支正准备为新战争招募士兵的军队。准军事化被植入了CrossFit的文化中。CrossFit甚至推出了一系列以在反恐战争中牺牲的士兵命名的训练项目。
You can go to the website and you can find an image of the man who died and a workout named after him. And they're called Hero Workouts. The Hero and Tribute Workouts now also include cops who've died in the line of duty. But ultimately, this is the culture that really made weightlifting mainstream in America. More so than Bob Hoffman or Joe Weeter ever could.
你可以访问网站，找到牺牲者的照片，以及以他名字命名的训练项目。它们被称为“英雄训练”。现在，“英雄与致敬训练”也包括了因公殉职的警察。但归根结底，正是这种文化真正让举重在美国成为了主流。这比Bob Hoffman或Joe Weider所能做到的要多得多。
Even though CrossFit was actively developed to be rogue and fringy. CrossFit was built in opposition to a mainstream gym. Now, you can go into any mainstream gym and find functional fitness spaces. And gyms throughout the country have like revamped and you know, their spaces to accommodate that, because it's been so popular. Think about the equipment that sold out in the pandemic. It's like kettlebells and barbells. Stuff that was all revived by CrossFit. Or rather, rather functional fitness.
尽管CrossFit被积极地开发为叛逆和边缘化的项目。CrossFit的建立是为了对抗主流健身房。现在，你可以走进任何一家主流健身房，找到功能性健身区。全国各地的健身房都进行了改造，以适应这种需求，因为它太受欢迎了。想想疫情期间卖断货的设备。比如壶铃和杠铃。这些都是被CrossFit复兴的东西。或者说，是功能性健身。
I can't use CrossFit because it's branded. Also, a lot of people don't want to use the name CrossFit because of its long history of being libertarian and white and militaristic and male, especially after the murder of George Floyd, when Greg Glassman tweeted racist things and was ousted from CrossFit corporate. A lot of people will not continue with CrossFit because of the undercurrent white supremacist imperialism misogyny that's inherent to the practice. It would be disingenuous and it would be maybe even borderline dishonest if I didn't give credit to CrossFit despite the shitty part. Maylard Howell is one of the founders of to CrossFit, despite the shitty part.
我不能使用CrossFit这个词，因为它是品牌化的。此外，很多人不想使用CrossFit这个名字，因为它有着悠久的自由意志主义、白人至上、军国主义和男性主导的历史，特别是在乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀后，Greg Glassman发布了种族主义推文并被CrossFit公司驱逐。很多人因为这种实践中固有的白人至上主义、帝国主义和厌女症的潜流而不会继续参与CrossFit。如果我不承认CrossFit尽管有糟糕的一面，却依然有贡献，那将是不真诚的，甚至可能近乎虚伪。Maylard Howell是Dean CrossFit的创始人之一。
Maylard Howell is one of the founders of Dean CrossFit in Brooklyn. It's one of only a few black-owned CrossFit gyms in New York City. And a lot of CrossFit gyms have changed their names or disassociated from the brand, but Dean CrossFit was not one of those gyms. We tried to be an example of what it should be or what it could be. Maylard started lifting through bodybuilding. When he was young he wanted to look like Arnold Schwarzenegger. Yeah that's how I started. I chased wanting to look like those guys in the magazine. That's how I started doing push-ups in my
Maylard Howell是布鲁克林Dean CrossFit的创始人之一。它是纽约市为数不多的黑人拥有的CrossFit健身房之一。许多CrossFit健身房更改了名称或与该品牌脱离了关系，但Dean CrossFit并非其中之一。我们试图成为它应该是什么或可以是什么的榜样。Maylard通过健美开始举重。他年轻时想看起来像阿诺德·施瓦辛格。是的，我就是那样开始的。我追求那种看起来像杂志里那些家伙的样子。我就是那样开始在妈妈的车库里做俯卧撑的。
mom's garage. But when Maylard was compelled to try a crossfit class he realized his muscles couldn't actually help him. And I was like, whoa, that shit kicked my ass. And there's either two reactions to that. Either that shit kicked my ass. I don't ever want to do that again, or ever feel like that again. Or two, shit, I kicked my ass. I got to do better. I think I could my ass. I got to do better. I could do, I think I could do better. No, I may be an anomaly, you know.
但当Maylard被迫尝试CrossFit课程时，他意识到他的肌肉实际上帮不了他。我当时想，哇，那玩意儿真让我吃尽了苦头。对此有两种反应。要么是：那玩意儿真让我吃尽苦头。我再也不想做那个了，或者再也不想有那种感觉了。或者第二种：该死，我让自己吃尽苦头了。我得做得更好。我想我能做得更好。我得做得更好。我想我能做得更好。不，我可能是一个特例，你知道。
But it has, you know, I don't think CrossFit or the functional fitness space would be where it's at right now without that raw. It appealed to a large percentage of fitness goers. For a male art functional fitness is about what your body can achieve, not what it looks like. Just right out of the Bob Hoffman camp. It's almost like he took the words right out of Bob's mouth when he said. Everyone should be lifting weights. Everyone. Everyone. I'm not saying you should be lifting weights to look like Arnold Schwarzenegger
但你知道，我不认为如果没有那种原始感，CrossFit或功能性健身空间会有今天的地位。它吸引了很大一部分健身爱好者。对Maylard来说，功能性健身关乎你的身体能实现什么，而不是它看起来怎么样。这简直直接出自Bob Hoffman的阵营。当他说“每个人都应该举重。每个人。每个人。我不是说你应该为了看起来像阿诺德·施瓦辛格而举重”时，简直就像直接引用了Bob的话。
or whatever. No. You should be lifting weights to improve your quality of life. You should be lifting weights to be a stronger human, to be a healthier human, to be able to do day-to-day stuff with minimal risk and increase your longevity. That's why you should be lifting weights, period. In a functional fitness class, you might encounter kettlebells and dumbbells or barbells. But in the class, I just so happen to go to, we were given barbells. And we were instructed how to clean and jerk with coordination and flexibility.
或者其他什么。不。你应该为了提高生活质量而举重。你应该为了成为一个更强壮的人、一个更健康的人、能够以最小的风险进行日常活动并增加寿命而举重。这就是你为什么要举重，句号。在功能性健身课上，你可能会遇到壶铃、哑铃或杠铃。但在我恰好参加的那节课上，我们被分到了杠铃。我们被指导如何协调且灵活地进行抓举和挺举。
Olympic style. You want your elbows to be up, full clustering, and the bar is actually resting on your shoulders. Are you always consciously considering the choreography or at some point does it become 6-style. Greenpoint athletics, formerly known as CrossFit Greenpoint, is gritty and raw feeling out of been way too intimidated to go by myself, but my friend Tori and her wife, Chris, have been going a lot lately. And they have computer-centric brain-in-a-jar jobs, like me, Chris is a law professor, and Tori is a writer.
奥林匹克风格。你希望肘部向上，完全聚拢，杠铃实际上是靠在你的肩膀上。你是否总是自觉地考虑动作编排，还是在某个时刻它变成了某种风格？Greenpoint Athletics，前身为CrossFit Greenpoint，感觉粗犷而原始，我本来太胆怯而不敢一个人去，但我的朋友Tori和她的妻子Chris最近经常去。她们和我一样，从事着以电脑为中心、像“罐中大脑”一样的工作，Chris是法学教授，Tori是作家。
I'm Tori Peters, what should I say? Author. Okay, I'm an author. I don't know. Bidden is a fishy anado, as of like three months ago. After a lot of instruction for how to execute an Olympic lift without throwing it back, I spent 20 minutes trying to sync my breath with my movements to hoist my barbell over my head. And it required a lot of focus.
我是Tori Peters，我该说什么？作家。好吧，我是个作家。我不知道。我三个月前成了健身爱好者。在接受了大量关于如何执行奥林匹克举重动作而不伤到背部的指导后，我花了20分钟试图将呼吸与动作同步，以便将杠铃举过头顶。这需要高度的专注。
My whole body and mind was induced into this very translike, beatific state. And I didn't feel competitive or like anyone else was looking at me. It was just me and this weight and some really loud music. I feel, I get to feel good about my body here, not because it's necessarily the way it looks, but like instead of being like, I want my body to be ornamental,
我的整个身心都进入了一种非常类似恍惚的、极乐的状态。我没有感到竞争，也不觉得有人在看着我。只有我和这个重量，还有一些非常大声的音乐。我觉得，我在这里能对自己的身体感觉良好，不是因为它看起来一定是什么样，而是，与其说“我想要我的身体具有装饰性”，
I start aspiring for my body to be able to do cheese. I didn't know what this movement is, but they're really pull-ups while ladder. Right on cue, the teacher who taught the class, Kylie, started doing these ridiculously intimidating pull-ups, like just as some sort of cool down. I think when I see people do these movements, I don't look at them. I can imagine what it movements, I don't look at them. I can imagine what it would like to do that. And instead of even as like an aspirational attainment, aspiring to be in my body, as opposed to aspiring to have somebody like gaze on my body, is a really big difference. And so like, the Olympic lifting class made my whole body ache in this satisfying way that felt pulsating.
我开始渴望我的身体能够做到某些事情。我不知道这个动作是什么，但她们确实在做引体向上。就在这时，教这门课的老师Kylie开始做这些极其吓人的引体向上，就像某种冷身运动一样。我想当我看到人们做这些动作时，我不会盯着他们看。我可以想象做那个动作是什么感觉。与其说这是一种渴望达到的成就，不如说渴望掌控自己的身体，而不是渴望别人审视我的身体，这有很大的不同。所以，奥林匹克举重课让我的全身都以一种令人满足的方式酸痛，感觉在跳动。
And I was like, huh, I think I could see myself getting into this. But I wasn't sure if I was considering it for weeder reasons or Hoffman reasons, you know? Like, did I actually want to be strong? Or did I just want to look like I was strong? Arguably functional fitness kind of blurs that line. Body building is supposed to be ornamental and then CrossFit is like, oh, it's applicable, but there's something ornamental and having a body that's so easily applicable to work.
我当时想，嗯，我想我能看到自己沉迷于此。但我不知道我是在出于Weider的原因还是Hoffman的原因考虑它，你知道吗？我是真的想变强吗？还是我只是想看起来很强壮？可以说功能性健身模糊了那条界线。健美运动应该是装饰性的，而CrossFit则说，哦，它是实用的，但拥有一个如此容易应用于工作的身体，本身也带有一种装饰性。
It's like, it's work that you'll never actually do. And it's like, yeah, I said it on my computer all day, but I could, I don't know, like, chop down a tree. And so there's a kind of like, it's like a hidden ornamentalism of the body. It's a set of considerations and circumstances that seem so far removed from Muscle Town USA and from the Olympics and from fears of muscle boundness
这就像是你永远不会真正去做的体力活。就像是，是的，我整天坐在电脑前，但我可以，我不知道，比如，砍倒一棵树。所以这是一种身体的隐藏装饰主义。这是一套考虑因素和环境，看起来与“美国肌肉城”、奥林匹克运动会以及对“肌肉僵硬”的恐惧相去甚远，
and from the Mount Rose Cemetery in York, Pennsylvania, where Bob Hoffman's grave was designed to look like Elvis Presley's, but engraved with a long-gloving list of his many accomplishments. At one time I stood alone, I was the only believer in weight training for athletics. Now there are millions. But Bob didn't need all the Braggery and the fake metals. As Legacy speaks for itself, I'll be at more quietly and subtly than Bob would have liked it to. Because when I took that class at Greenpoint Athletics, the 2.5 pound plates I kept adding to my barbell each time I lifted it high above my head. We're emblazoned in iron with the name York. Nice try is a product of curved and the Vox Media podcast network.
也与宾夕法尼亚州约克市的Mount Rose公墓相去甚远，Bob Hoffman的墓碑被设计成看起来像猫王埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的墓碑，但上面刻着他许多成就的长长清单。曾几何时，我孤身一人，我是唯一相信体育运动需要重量训练的人。现在有数百万人了。但Bob不需要所有的吹嘘和假奖牌。他的遗产本身就说明了一切，尽管比Bob所希望的要安静和微妙得多。因为当我参加Greenpoint Athletics的那节课时，我每次将杠铃高举过头顶时不断增加的2.5磅杠铃片，上面都用铁铸着“York”的名字。Nice Try是Curved和Vox Media播客网络的产物。
You can find more episodes wherever you listen. This week, Avery will be talking about the origin of the Western bathroom and the culture of modern cleanliness, as examined through the great mystery of why Americans cannot seem to fully embrace the Bade. Embrace the Badei. Embrace the Badei people is delightful. Nice try is written and performed by Avery Trufflement, produced by Megan Kanane, with associate producers Diana Buds and Sarah Burke, fact-checked by Selena Solan. Lisa Pollock is their editorial consultant with sound design and engineering by Alex Higgins.
你可以在你收听节目的任何地方找到更多剧集。本周，Avery将讨论西方浴室的起源和现代清洁文化，通过探讨为什么美国人似乎无法完全接受坐浴盆这一伟大谜团来审视。接受坐浴盆。接受坐浴盆的人真是令人愉快。Nice Try由Avery Trufflement撰写和表演，Megan Kanane制作，Diana Buds和Sarah Burke担任助理制作人，Selena Solan负责事实核查。Lisa Pollock是他们的编辑顾问，Alex Higgins负责声音设计和工程。
Their showrunner is Art Chung, an executive producers are Nisha Kurwa and Kelsey Keith. This program 99% of visible is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead, Swan Rial, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lashima Donz, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown Oakland California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook you can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org or on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Esteture shows I love as well as
他们的节目统筹是Art Chung，执行制片人是Nisha Kurwa和Kelsey Keith。这个节目99%的可见度（99% Invisible）团队包括Delaney Hall、Kurt Colstead、Swan Rial、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Le、Joe Rosenberg、Chris Baroube、Christopher Johnson、Lashima Donz、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员，总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论，你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI.org，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注。你也可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及
every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Okay, I want you to do eight reps of stitcher followed by 12 reps of Sirius XM. Okay, here we go. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99PI的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。好了，我希望你做8次Stitcher重复动作，接着做12次Sirius XM重复动作。好了，我们开始吧。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。